♪ ♪
>> IF THEY HAD SPIES IN MY
CAMPAIGN, DURING MY CAMPAIGN FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES, THAT WOULD
BE UNPRECEDENTED IN THE HISTORY
OF OUR COUNTRY.
THAT WOULD BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
INSULTS THAT ANYONE HAS EVER
SEEN AND IT WOULD BE VERY
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
WEREN'T.
I HOPE THERE WEREN'T, FRANKLY.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT TODAY
TALKING ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE INVESTIGATORS IN THIS
INFORMANT, SPY, WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT IN THE REPORTS
OF IT IN 2016.
BACK WITH THE PANEL.
KIMBERLEY, YOU FOLLOWED THIS
CLOSELY.
WHERE IS IT GOING?
>> MOST RECENTLY WE HAVE THE
PRESIDENT HAVE A SIT DOWN
OBVIOUSLY WITH DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN
AND FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER
WRAY AND SAY LOOK, YOU NEED TO
COOPERATE WITH CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATORS.
GET THESE DOCUMENTS OUT SO WE
CAN SEE THE TRUTH ABOUT THIS
INFORMANT OR WHETHER THERE WERE
ANY MORE.
LOOK, I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE EVEN IN CONGRESS STILL
SKEPTICAL THEY ARE GOING TO GET
TO SEE THE DOCUMENTS.
SO FAR THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAS ONLY WANTED TO BRIEF THEM TO
KEEP A TIGHT HOLD OVER IT, AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE PROOF OF
WHETHER OR NOT THE PRESIDENT'S
MESSAGE GETS THROUGH.
ARE THEY ALLOWED TO REVIEW THE
MATERIAL THEMSELVES RATHER THAN
JUST GO ON THE WORD OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OFFICIALS?
>> Bret: LAWMAKERS WEIGHING IN
YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT WHERE THEY
STAND POLITICALLY IS KIND OF
WHERE THEY STAND ON THIS EFFORT.
>> EXTRAORDINARILY TROUBLING IF
THIS WHITE HOUSE IS TRYING TO
FORCE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITIES TO
DIVULGE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
FOR PARTISAN REASONS.
>> IF SUCH A MEETING OCCURS, AND
I DON'T BELIEVE IT SHOULD, BUT
IF IT OCCURS, IT MUST BE
BIPARTISAN.
>> IT IS SCHEDULED TO TAKE PLACE
ON THURSDAY OF THIS WEEK.
EXPECTED TO INTEND OUR CHAIRMAN
NUNES, CHAIRMAN GOWDY, FBI
DIRECTOR WRAY, DAN COATS, AND ED
O'CALLAGHAN.
>> Bret: MEETING ON THURSDAY
ORCHESTRATED BY THE WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF BUT THAT'S THE
GROUP THAT'S GOING TO BE THERE
THURSDAY.
IDEALLY THEY THINK TO GET THEIR
CLASSIFIED MATERIALS.
>> I HAVE TO SAY I THINK
CHUCK SCHUMER HAS A POINT.
IF THIS IS ABOUT CONGRESSIONAL
ACCESS TO THESE VITAL MATERIALS,
WHY SHOULDN'T IT BE BIPARTISAN?
THE DEMOCRATIC RANKING MEMBER OF
THAT COMMITTEE IS CLEARED AS
WELL.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
CREATE THE IMPRESSION THAT THIS
IS PARTISANSHIP IN THE OTHER
DIRECTION.
THAT THERE IS A REAL PRINCIPLE
AT STAKE HERE.
THIS IS A VERY, VERY UNCHARTED
AREA.
THE IDEA OF THE INDEPENDENCE OF
THE INTELLIGENCE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITIES IS
NOT WRITTEN IN THE CONSTITUTION.
IT'S KIND OF A NORM THAT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED SINCE WATERGATE
REALLY.
FAIRLY RECENTLY IN OUR HISTORY.
IT'S BEING TESTED RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT WHETHER
IT CAN WITHSTAND THIS
HYPERPARTISAN ATMOSPHERE WE ARE
IN AND THE OBVIOUS FURY OF A
PRESIDENT WHO COMES FROM OUTSIDE
THE SYSTEM AND OUTSIDE THAT
HISTORY.
HIS BELIEF THAT THIS MACHINERY
GOT TURNED AGAINST HIM.
IT'S NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR TO ME
THAT IT WAS BEING TURNED AGAINST
HIM, AT LEAST NOT IN EXTREMELY
POWERFUL OR VICIOUS WAYS.
THE WAY HE IS DESCRIBING IT.
SOUNDS LIKE THIS HALPER GUY WAS
TRYING TO KEEP TABS ON CARTER
PAGE LATE IN THE SUMMER.
THAT'S NOT EXACTLY EMBEDDING A
SPY IN THE CAMPAIGN.
>> Bret: WHAT I SAY ABOUT BOTH
SIDES OF THE INVESTIGATION EVERY
TIME ON THE PANEL IS WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT WE DON'T KNOW.
BYRON.
>> THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
AND WHAT CHUCK WAS TALKING
ABOUT, THEY NOT ONLY HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
WRATH OR THE PARTISAN SITUATION
ON CAPITOL HILL.
THEY ALSO HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THEIR OWN ACTIONS.
THIS WAS AN ELECTION IN WHICH
THE FBI HAD BOTH MAJOR PARTY
CANDIDATES UNDER INVESTIGATION.
MAYBE THEY HAVE BEEN TOO
INVOLVED IN POLITICS AND MAYBE
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
GET TOO INVOLVED IN POLITICS.
AS FAR AS THE MEETING IS
CONCERNED, WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
REPUBLICANS HAVE GOTTEN VERY
WARY OF THE SORT OF THINGS BY
UNHAPPY EXPERIENCE IN WHICH THEY
THINK THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO TURN
SOMETHING OVER AND THEN THEY
SHOW UP IN THE ROOM AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT JUST WANTS TO
TALK ABOUT TURNING SOMETHING
OVER.
BUT IN THE END, ESPECIALLY IF
THEY THE SUPPORT NOT JUST OF THE
PRESENT BUT ESPECIALLY HOUSE
SPEAKER PAUL RYAN, IF THEY HAVE
THAT SUPPORT, THEY ARE PROBABLY
GOING TO GET WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR.
>> Bret: LAST WORD, KIMBERLEY.
WRAP IT UP AS WE WILL FOLLOW
EACH OF THESE DEVELOPMENTS AS
THEY COME.
>> I THINK ONE PROBLEM WITH
THOSE WHO CRITICIZE THIS
OVERSIGHT BY THE HOUSE AS THEY
BEGIN FROM THE PREMISE THAT THE
INVESTIGATORS ARE BEYOND
REPROACH OR BEYOND BEING LOOKED
AT.
GIVEN WHAT IS OUT THERE ALREADY
ABOUT THE FISA ABUSES, USE OF A
DOSSIER AS PART OF THE FISA